it's absolutely delicious i'm biting
into a fried rice ball there's really
like nothing that could go wrong
hi i'm jen and today i'm going to show
you how to make japanese inspired
arancini so for this recipe it uses
dried mushrooms and we're going to
rehydrate them by cooking them in water
so when you're done don't get rid of the
cooking water that's actually super
important we need that for the broth
well okay obviously i like this dish
because it tastes super good but also it
has significance to me as well because
it's one of the first dishes that i
learned how to make after i came out
cooking and especially for me cooking
for other people was something that i
was always super anxious to do but i
guess after i came out i was sort of
like that was the bravest thing that i
could have done it just sort of
jump-started my confidence and all of a
sudden cooking for people no longer
seems scary aren't you combines my
favorite things which is rice and
crunchy foods when you first bite into
it it's super crispy and then the rice
and the shiitake mushrooms just kind of
melt in your mouth it's a dish i was
drawn to because i feel like it's a
small homage to my japanese and italian
heritage and before i even really knew
what that meant i knew what japanese
food was and i knew what italian food
was like my strongest memories as a kid
were just eating and i thought it would
be really fun to combine the two
cultures to make something super
delicious i really like to cook this
dish because it's super hearty and
savory but also vegetarian friendly i'm
a lesbian and if i didn't cater to
vegetarians i probably wouldn't be able
to cook for like half my friends so i
think it's important i really just gotta
work on not panicking when cooking for
other people because when i think
something tastes good i really want
other people to think it tastes good but
the nice thing about this arancini is
that i know it tastes good so if you
don't like it there's something wrong
with you and not me i grew up surrounded
by a huge family on both sides and food
was always such a big part of our family
gatherings that i've been surrounded by
people who love to cook my whole life
and i'm really grateful that i have like
a wealth of family recipes to draw from
because sometimes cooking is like one of
the ways that we can feel at home even
when we're super far from all the people
we love when i think about lgbtq kids
and them growing up and what i'd like to
say i mostly just want everyone to know
that like coming out and being open
about your identity is like a very
personal thing and it's not something
that you have to do at any point in time
it's something that you can decide when
it's safe you can decide when you feel
comfortable to do and i think honestly
despite me talking about like bravery
and confidence sometimes the bravest
thing you can do is to just take care of
yourself and that doesn't always mean
coming out on when you think somebody
thinks you should your safety is the
most important thing and i always want
people to protect themselves and look
out for themselves in that way my
favorite thing to say is just like come
out come out whenever you're ready it's
not hide and seek it's not come out come
out wherever you are it's whenever
you're ready that's the best way of
putting it i think happy pride month
everyone we're gay or not we're all just
a bunch of big queer people it's gonna
be fine we're having a good time queer
people we've been here through so much
uh we have so many elders and people
that we need to be grateful for it's
just it's a good time to celebrate that
and i'm so thankful for all of you we
deserve the best oh yes
you